let's jump to this story this one's a
good one so we have this uh fact check
from WTHR viral video of Biden saying
he's reinstating the draft is a deep
fake in the video President Joe Biden
appears to say he's reinstating the
draft so the U.S can help defend Ukraine
against Russian forces the video is a
deep figure I love that this was fact
checked because it was made by turning
point it was on Jack pesobic's show and
he outright says that it's not a real
like he explains we are showing you of
what is to come and it's like it's meant
to be provocative and then the media is
like uh oh people might think this is
real all right well here's why I think
this is worth talking about
election season's coming up we are going
to see deep fakes and they are going to
improve at the speed of Maximum economic
investment and they're going to be
hilarious yeah but some of them are
gonna be scary but yeah hilarious too
like the one of Joe Biden and Trump
playing OverWatch which is one of the
funniest they keep making them there's
one with um Joe Rogan and Jordan
Peterson and then Elon comes in he's
like you sons of I can't I can't
fight the boss the OverWatch
no but the OverWatch one was good he was
like Jesus Christ I come in here try to
get a Quick Queue and it's bidenator and
it's Trump saying it but uh
no what I think we're going to see is
how much money do they invest in
presidential elections it's it's got to
be what billions billions it was it was
I think Obama was a billion so now
imagine how much money is going to be on
both sides for an election especially
with how crazy things are getting in
this country
and they are going to be investing
people are going to invest tens of
millions into advancing deep fake
technology I guarantee it right now
some political person I don't care what
political party saw this and they said
if we can make this impeccable we will
never lose another election again
and so they're meeting right now with
deep fake companies saying and and I bet
a lot of it is is totally like
seemingly on the level some guy who's
got nefarious intentions goes to an AI
company and says hey I want to invest a
you know a billion dollars into the
development of the technology and they
go wow that's really great thank you for
the funding and what they intend to do
with it is make realistic videos that
are indistinguishable
and so my fear is
not that you'll see a video go viral of
Joe Biden reinstating the draft why well
people are going to be like get out of
here he never did as a deep fake but
what they'll do is you'll have a real
video of Donald Trump say uh saying we
should condemn them totally referring to
White supremacists and neo-nazis and
what they'll do is they'll make an
impeccable deep fake replica where he
should says and some of them should be
condemned totally a very minor
difference but a drastic change in the
context and then you run it on CNN and
then if they get caught they're just
like we didn't know and not even no it's
not even that they're gonna say that's
the video and then Trump's going to sue
and say that is not what was said here's
the actual report and you're gonna say
look there's 12 different videos all
seemingly of the exact same thing we
don't know which one's the real one
because everybody knows Trump gave the
speech everybody know knows Trump says
something about condemning Nazis but the
only difference is they should be and
some of them should be it's like a
weapon it's like the strike first kind
of thing like well the ethics of
striking first is you know beyond me I
don't know what's going to happen is
Democrats will share the video of trump
going and I'm not talking about the
white nationalists because some of them
should be condemned totally and they're
going to go he said some of them like
he's implying all there may be some good
ones there and they're all going to
share it and it's going to infect that
bubble and then you're gonna get the
right being like no no he said they
should be who talking about all of them
and there's going to be two different
versions of one news event existing for
both different political factions so
it's going to be no different than it is
now that I mean that's very different
right I mean they're listening to the
same thing and having yes but you can
still so I I was a uh at a family
holiday event and I was talking about
how China was potentially getting access
to the DNA from covid tests and you know
one individual was like what get out of
here that's BS that's not true you can't
say that and then I just pulled up my
phone pulled up NPR reporting it and I
handed to him they read and they went oh
wow I didn't know that and I'm like
you're sitting here thinking I'm wrong
about this I was just I NPR of all
sources what happens when they go no and
they pull up a video and they show you
the video and you go that's not a real
video they'll say you're a conspiracy
theorist and you're lying I have the
video
so what's the best way to authenticate
those though impossible defects yeah we
were talking about that today in one of
our development meetings I don't know I
think it's going to have to be either
the person verifies the video themselves
and if it's a video of you that you
don't verify then there's no
verification I think it's going to be a
lot easier to verify the real ones
rather than sniffing out all the fake
ones but then people like project
Veritas will try and catch someone
they'll be like no I don't that wasn't a
real video so you've got to be like at
some point
um the other idea is to build like a
headset or some sort of tech that you
can use that can see that it's a deep
fix somehow no that can tell if it's AI
you got you got you got to understand
the the full sphere of what this what
this means a video will come out of say
a guy at Pfizer saying something
ridiculous like we're mutating the virus
or you know who knows what yeah and then
what will happen is
a Veritas like organization will say
here's a video of the guy saying they're
mutating the virus
what they'll then do is they will make
using that video another deep fake and
say ah yes but here's the part they cut
out and then all of a sudden you'll see
another video where the guy goes could
you imagine if like someone from these
companies had something as crazy as
we're mutating these viruses so that we
can make more money that would be insane
and then everyone will go oh Veritas cut
the context out he was talking about how
crazy it would have been if someone did
it no he didn't actually say it wow that
proves Veritas is lying you see the
point I could see that in other cases in
a case like Veritas they they I mean
they have all the footage
yeah but but how do you prove a negative
if an organization to defend itself deep
fakes your video you can't prove the
video doesn't exist you can only prove a
video does exist so you'll get a video
of trump saying something like you know
we're gonna build a big beautiful wall
and then the left will you'll get a
combination of offensive and defensive
deep fakes the left will make a video
where Trump is like saying something
somewhat offensive to add context making
it seem like he's racist and then to
defend against it the Republicans will
add another bit where Trump is saying
can you believe what so-and-so said he
said this and they'll just keep trying
to change the context with defects
think about what happens if you you get
filmed and someone leaks audio of you
saying something offensive you can be a
lot you you can say hey that's out of
context that I wasn't actually saying
probably wasn't so if Ian came on the
show and said I don't like buttered
popcorn and that clip went viral people
would be like wow he doesn't like butter
popcorn if Ian said no no that's bad he
would just make a deep fake of him
saying I would never say something like
I don't like buttered popcorn and that
inverts the context and that's what you
can do with the fakes too it's going to
be wild man a billion dollars per Camp
campaign plus and how much of that money
can get invested in making stuff like
this remember the meme Wars in 2015-16
it ramp it up baby because you're going
to get a combination of you're going to
get subliminal liminal and super liminal
deep fakes super liminal defects are
going to be someone being like and
here's a new meme of Joe Biden singing
The Chicken Song and it'll just be Joe
Biden it'll be silly then you'll get
stuff that are liminal I'm doing air
quotes a Simpsons joke that are more
like what Jack besobic did where it's
some people might get confused by it but
he says what he's doing and then the
subliminal is when they just leak stuff
and then don't say anything about it and
people fall for it they should do one of
fetterman
I mean that'd be cool but it would just
be here yeah how would you how would you
know if he if they released a deep fake
of fetterman right now saying look
here's your proof of life exactly
and then what happens when get this
John
hodgkinson runs for Senate
and everyone sees videos of him staying
at the podium cheering everybody sees
interviews with him talking about his
policies
and there is no John hodgkinson it's a
AI deep fake character
that appears in the media that appears
on YouTube that does this campaigning
and you'll see people in YouTube their
cheering form he'll have commercials
where he says vote for me because I
believe in making America great again
and that everyone's like I'm gonna vote
for this guy and he's not real I think
you made a good point that if if
fetterman had a deep fake uh because
when when they did fake Biden it's
obvious it's a deep fake a lot of times
because you you can't hear the
imperfections like you can't hear the
degraded quality in his brain
um and a lot of times when people do
perfect yeah and when people are singing
with songs if the machine builds it you
can kind of tell it's like robotically
perfect and so there's this imperfective
quality to human behavior that possibly
cannot be captured by a computer if we
could somehow perceive that in certain
contexts I at least agree with that yeah
I think it will be though and that's
what's scary is I feel like the
technology is evolving a lot quicker
than we are I feel like we're pretty
dumb compared to what we've created
people a lot of this chaos is coming
from because we are not equipped or
evolved to live in the world we create
those videos of like Jen's ears being
like why do I have to have a job they
are going to be the first in line to go
into the pod
they're going to say you know you're
right about this you shouldn't have to
step into pod where we will hook feeding
tubes right into your gullet and then
put the VR helmet on and you'll live in
digital world where you can be whatever
you want I thought you meant the suicide
Booth well that too created that
mentality by making it so miserable to
live and survive for these kids I mean I
do gen Z gets a bad rap for being so
nonchalant about it but wouldn't you
you're never gonna own anything most of
them are not going to own houses or cars
or anything
so I don't really blame them I've been
lied to about most things
um and especially like the gender stuff
like think about being a Ave them on
hormones working at Starbucks and
they're like 20 mobile orders like I
wouldn't and then you have like social
anxiety disorder and stuff and like they
all have disorders I mean it's just like
it's not an enviable position it's
boring I agree with that but like you
talk look at people come back from the
jungle after losing a leg like I don't
see
combat vets complaining and bitching
Adrian Curry says send them to Ukraine I
agree that's the thing and all the tick
tockers to Ukraine any any one of these
people who wants to leave Ukrainian flag
and complain about what's going on I say
we send them right over
you know like it's it's hard I do agree
that life has become treacherously dull
for people especially being lied to
about the military-industrial complex
and then realizing you're part of the
Empire is like what the what am I
doing I mean the reason they wouldn't go
to Ukraine is because they're like
languishing the fact that they know
they're useless like that's that's they
know that they that they would instantly
die their situation and that's like
demoralizing even worse
how much you want to bet winsinger that
story of you will live in the Pod you
will eat the bugs you will own nothing
and you will be happy they're probably
going please it can't come soon enough
they are they are I will tell you gen Z
has that attitude you know I I see a lot
of the dialogue especially when they're
talking about you know if there was an
apocalypse they're saying wow you guys
will to live is incredible I just let
I'd let it all happen so I think these
kids are severely depressed I think they
don't really have much purpose because
we've hyper fixated on individualism and
this narcissistic Society so these kids
are just focusing on only themselves and
they have a meaningless life because
they have no other purpose except
themselves so once we took away that
Community not even themselves yeah yeah
well the future's sounding pretty good
huh I imagine kids are like the ultimate
purpose I because I've been gaming a lot
and just keep thinking like what is the
freaking purpose of life I keep rinsing
and repeating the same thing there's no
goal there's no like quest to salt to
finish there's no experience gained I
don't get the ding when I do the thing
it's just non-stop abominable human
spirit and like the the drive to produce
the Next Generation to do what though
eat more candy bars and watch more TV
like what that's what I'm going through
and I think having children is a big
part I haven't done a space
maybe it's different for everybody
Explorations for some people see see my
my dreams for the future cannot be
accomplished in a single lifetime you
know I I am not driven by having a fancy
car or an infinity pool I'm driven at
the thought of a spaceship traveling the
Galaxy with a bunch of people on it
being like you know we're 17 light years
away sir engage warp you know I should
have signed up there
you know maybe maybe
people get bored of that too like I've
tripped my balls off and seen the
craziest stuff and and like experience
the most
I mean bending reality and it's still
just like now what like even while I'm
tripping I'm like okay the bug is
dancing on my arm what is this all
things will die and I'm like crying
relationships
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time